welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and I'm Jessica Clemens and we are
Jericho Jerica and we are breaking out
Daredevil season one episode five world
on fire in this Daredevil rewatch series
The Road to born again we are breaking
down all 39 episodes of the three
seasons of Netflix's Daredevil and after
fist got creative with a car door last
week he's now scrambling to pin
anatoly's death on the man in Black and
if you're listening to me and you're
like Jessica your voice is weird I lost
my voice coffee to my sleep I'm fine and
I have a Sprite here now so you will see
me drinking it we open on Claire wiping
shower Steam from Matt's bathroom mirror
to examine her various bruises it seems
like the episodes in this show always
take place directly after the previous
one it doesn't give us a break from
anything to catch our breath so that's
why everyone's bruised and always
limping so this is Claire the morning
after a traumatic encounter with the
Russians which she clearly still working
to get through she stayed the night at
Matt's place but we see some blankets
and a pillow folded up on the couch so
it's clear they didn't sleep together
yet
Matt's being a gentleman by making his
battered house guest some breakfast and
Claire asked this you have a job or
something to get to are you one of those
billionaire Playboys I'm always hearing
about the
SE nod to Tony Stark who revealed to the
world that he's Iron Man but it could
also be a nod to Comics like Batman and
great Arrow since it's been established
at the DC movies and Comics exist in the
MCU Matt explains that he's a lawyer
with his own practice so Claire should
be happy I mean she doesn't know that
their practice is broken has zero
clients yet and in this scene Claire is
truly the voice of the audience she's
asking all the questions you always wish
people would ask these superheroes like
how the hell are you a lawyer by day in
the Vigilante by night and hey how do
your abilities work and if the show's
credit Matt actually gives her an
amazing answer you just opened one of
the cuts on your back
how do you know that
yeah taste copper in the air he also
explains that he can tell that she
doesn't have any broken bones because he
can't hear any grinding which is kind of
gross because he's gotta imagine this
guy's walking by everybody with broken
bones being like but he uses all these
senses to feel the balance and the
direction the temperature vibration
stuff he hears and smells it all equals
superpowers it makes sense to us and
then we get the exchange that's every
bfx artist nightmare all of the
fragments form a sort of
impressionistic painting what is that
look like
what do you
actually see the world's on fire
hey just the title of the episode yeah
so here we get another art reference
which is an ongoing thing throughout
this series last episode we made the
point that they're trying to show Matt
and Fisk as two sides of the same coin
and this got his own art themed episode
rabbit in a snowstorm Matt's painting is
fire discs is I suck it's also worth
noting that Matt's walls are devoid of
any art which will come into play later
when he goes to Vanessa's gallery to do
some Recon he pretends he wants to buy
art to warm his apartment up Matt asked
Claire to stay with him until he can
figure out a way she can stay safe from
the Russians and they finally kiss and
they kiss on the lips and you just know
the next time we see that couch it is
not gonna have guests blankets and
pillows on there hmm clear as Matt
another question the audience always
wonders which is why doesn't he just go
to the police and he tells her that
wearing a mask and beating on people
doesn't exactly mesh with the police
policy but we at least get some
semblance that Matt has some sort of
long-term goal for all of this when he
says this right here maybe I only need
to take down one man Fisk cut off the
head of the snake
oh you sweet naive man anyone familiar
with the MCU knows another similar
saying when it comes to villains cut off
one head and two more shall take its
place that's the Hydra motto but it can
apply here too given that Fisk is in a
league with gallon Nobu and a whole
bunch of other baddies now Claire says
that when the Russians were beating on
her she heard them say the name Vladimir
and we cut the man himself who doesn't
yet know about his poor headless brother
cut off one head and if you've got a
super pissed off Russian on your hands
Wesley shows up and proves he's a man of
many talents there are still a few small
details we'd like to iron out before
uh where's your brother dude his
brother's blood was splash on your face
last night Wesley would make one a poker
player Vlad responds last time I saw him
he was heading to see me
your employer Vladimir now catches
himself before saying fisk's name smart
move but this is the lesson he learned
too late since if he'd shown physical
respect to demand at all along his
brother wouldn't be doing his best Marie
Antoinette impression right now because
you know what we'll set this passion
Marines when it's had in a car tour they
don't die the history you learn it's
cool it's not it's not right so vlad's
goon comes into telling that they found
Anatoly and then they bring him in damn
Vlad has got to see his brother without
a head pretty harsh in anatoly's Pocket
is the man in Black's mask playing right
in a fisk's plan Vlad says to put every
man he has out on the street to find him
and bring him his head and we cut to the
bloody credits and then cut to anatoly's
blood being hosed off of fisk's car and
there's like bone and brain in there
it's just gnarly
I can't do it okay gal Nobu and Leland
are there and you just know Fisk is
letting them see this bloody scene as a
power play Move he tells them that the
Russians are out and he's the guy who
took off Angela's head and they're
understandably super pissed that they
were consulted beforehand or
before head I guess
ah this whole scene is shot in the
handheld shaky cam style which makes it
all more unsettling and disorienting
which is no doubt how GAO Nobu and
Leland all feel during this conversation
we all knew
that we would need to eliminate the
Russians one day
they were too unpredictable
this from a guy taking heads off with
the car door once again I love Leland's
smart ass style here he just tells it
like it is I think he's a great
character for this show him and Wesley
are great characters for the show fists
moves things over with the promise of
more money for all and we get this
ominous line from Nobu remember your
promise to me
and those I speak for this is played a
few different angles and we'll find out
more about this one later on in the
series yep next we get another classic
Daredevil one shot action sequence and
it's just as awesome in his mind
boggling as the hallway scene was we
start on one of gal's blind drug Runners
right in the back seat of a Russian taxi
cab and he's singing this hauntingly
beautiful song
So this actor is and he's singing in
Mandarin the song kingding chinga also
known as King Ding Love Song a popular
traditional folk song from kingding
China written by Wu and G the lyrics
talk about a lovely maid with a sweet
smile that the blacksmith's son comes to
court he came to court her in moonlights
Moonlight shines bright a courtship in
Moonlight and the following scene with
Matt fighting these Russians can be
considered a bit of a courtship By
Moonlight the camera starts inside the
cab right next to the singer and it
swivels back and forth and it's just
super cool like you can't even see the
camera or the crew or the camera man in
the rearview mirror at all at one point
it does a full 360 degree turn and Matt
is just standing there like a jump scare
in a horror movie you know like it I
think it was parallel Activity three
where the camera is pivoting back and
forth on the fan and then it's like
right there behind her and then the seat
drops down and it's kind of appropriate
given that the Russians now see him as
some sort of Boogeyman to Bubba yeah if
this were John Wick cutting off the
heads and appearing out of nowhere I
mean the camera swivels back around Matt
is now gone and again this is just all
one long unbroken take the show really
does an awesome job finding some
interesting and different ways to shoot
things that aren't just your typical
action fare and I hope they continue
this trend in the new series I'm born
again on Disney plus Matt takes out the
Russians one by one and at one point
this singer is sadly shot just more
bloody collateral damage left behind
that question is one of the man that's
the Vladimir's whereabouts at least I'll
tell you what you would just don't cut
the head off so this is Matt's first
indication that something is up but the
cops show up and he doesn't get a chance
to get more answers and he does the next
logical choice for info hey you guys
heard anything on the news about a
Russian getting his head cut off in
Hell's Kitchen this city bad enough you
get mug now I chop your melon off what's
next groping corpses dude Matt your
office Small Talk needs a lot of work
it's bad it's horrible get it up not the
way that you think that groping corpse
line is definitely a nod to what happens
before Julie Barnes in season three
which I talk about a lot and I love it I
don't love it I don't like what happens
to Julie Barnes I it's just crazy okay
let me go back Miss Cardenas comes in to
get these guys help she was referred to
them by Brett Mahoney's mom the one
foggy keeps buying cigars too even
though he's not supposed to the slumlord
Armin Tully is trying to drive Miss
Cardenas in the other low-income
residents out of their apartment complex
so he can put up the condos this is just
more evidence of fisk's plan to clean up
the city for the right people like you
mentioned to Vanessa last episode Karen
translates for Miss Cardenas even though
Matt also speaks Spanish and he tells
her do you want to do this no no I like
the central voice and that dirty dog
that's exactly what he told Claire last
episode he has run it out of lines get
your game up Sir hate you that's why you
keep ending up here
oh maybe I just like the sign
even foggy rolls his eyes inside I
rolled my eyes everybody's rolling their
eyes you see this before from him no
doubt absolutely not Matt and foggy
agree to take up the case and we find
out that Tully is wrapped by landman and
Zach the law firm where the guys used to
intern that also offer them jobs that
they turned down so they could form
Nelson and Murdoch Matt says he'll go to
the precinct while foggy and Karen hit
up the law firm boggy Likens the lawyers
to sharks and Matt says try not to
Splash too much it attracts him yeah
splashing around is exactly what Matt is
doing at night is a man in Black and
it's getting the attention of Fisk in a
big bad way Matt goes to the precinct to
ask for files on arm and Tully but he's
also really there to listen burning info
on the Headless Russian as Matt sits and
waits behind him as a poster that reads
you don't have to reveal your identity
to solve violent crimes so so
appropriate for a mask vigilante I think
one of my favorite shots at Easter eggs
in this whole season Matt is also one of
the superheroes who doesn't register as
an enhanced human after the sokovia
chords are passed so he chose not to
reveal his identity and in She-Hulk our
man was very very defensive of this
whole idea of superhero privacy over
Brett Mahoney's shoulder we get our Stan
Lee Cameo a framed photo of him as a
decorated police officer Matt hears
detectives Blake and Hoffman
interrogating Peter the Russian he beat
down the Night Before Peter asks him if
they know who he works for the cops
don't care about Vladimir and Anatoly
however which is the first indicator
these guys maybe know more about what's
going on in the criminal underworld than
they should if I give you another name
he have to be big he'd have to be king
freaking con big and King really taking
out any ambiguity over who Peter's gonna
name so obviously Peter gives up Fisk
and things goes out immediately the
detectives pause and then Blake undoes
Peter's handcuffs which is never a good
sign if you're ever in a movie and a cop
undoes your handcuffs in a private
interrogation room you're in trouble
whose turn is this yours
I thought I took a foreign
yeah unsurprisingly these detectives are
in fisk's pocket and there's this cool
shot of Matt standing up to react just a
moment before the gun goes off and every
cop behind him leaps into action behind
him in slow motion and you just know he
has a ton of things going through his
mind he already saw that fist can get a
jury to tamper with a trial and now he's
starting to get the scope of what he's
up against now a lot of people ask me
how I'm able to stay focused researching
all these videos and honestly it's one
of these
[Music]
focusing
so one shot energy juice are a healthy
and convenient energy boosting
supplement candy for gamers athletes
YouTube hosts everybody really they make
energy to choose and Focus Shoes the
focus shoes are really my go-to but it
really just depends on what you need
each energy chew has 75 milligrams of
pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional neurotropics that give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus choose now
available in limited edition new
rockstars themed packaging they really
help me concentrate and give a natural
boost of energy with BCD and E vitamins
plus zinc to help with immune system
support and the amino acid tyrosine both
the Energy Chews and focus chews are
plant-based naturally sweetened and
designed to give you the energy and
focus you need without a bunch of
fillers and chemicals get started with
one shot energy today by going to one
shotenergy.com new rockstars for 10 off
your order so Karen and foggy go to
landman and Zach land man and Zach such
a stupid name I hate saying that which
is huge and stands in direct contrast to
the Nelson and Murdock office with its
old ass office equipment and rats
chewing through the phone lines and when
we meet Marcy Stahl one of Tully's
lawyers and also foggy's ex who is
unfortunately very racist it ended Mrs
Carnitas tell you Cardenas yikes no
thank you
yeah you are a horrible person and I
hope you burn in hell
Marcy goes all in my client is doing the
city a favor by gentrifying that place
and driving current residents out and
tells foggy to tell his client to take
the deal or live in squalor also who
uses that live in squalor I hate her and
then foggy busts out some pretty badass
lawyer speak capped off with this so
you're gonna see us in court where I
will absolutely dismantle you from the
top of your salon blowout to the bottom
of your overpriced pumps sure go up
foggy we cut to Wesley and Fisk in their
black SUV and Fisk is clearly worried as
he rubs his natoya's cufflinks Wesley
tells Fitz that they are taking
statements from both cops who framed
Peter during the interrogation this
leaves an even more lengthy list of
crimes behind them something they've
been trying to avoid as Wesley mentioned
did Leland in episode three now clearly
Fisk is worried about more people using
his name if you use his name it's an
instant kill and his goon cops
immediately get the job done but how
many people know his name even Wesley
knows that Vladimir's list of people who
know fisk's name is getting short mainly
because they keep killing them because
is an uncultured boy man Wesley
recommends the 75 Brunello de Montalcino
a wine that ranges from 60 to 400 if you
remember the last time Vanessa and Fisk
went on a date Fisk admitted that he
didn't know what to order and his
assistant recommended appearing so we
could assume that this is their second
date for Fisk and Vanessa then we cut to
miss Cardenas apartment and yes it's
very sketchy but it is home the lights
flicker a man's unconscious on the floor
and the paint is peeling off the wall
the two shades of green paint don't help
it all looks like the corroding we saw
in young Matt's eyes the very first
episode when his sight was fading away
Karen and foggy make their way to miss
Cardenas apartment and the Damage Done
to this poor woman's apartment is
horrible there's no power so the only
lights eliminated in the room are the
street lights are outside a single
Lantern and so so many candles a
dangerous amount you might say if you
thought Jesus was going to sneak by this
episode think again miss Cardenas has a
beautifully framed photo of Jesus and a
Rosary that luckily wasn't damaged by
these Renovations these Renovations
buttholes foggy and Karen agree to help
Miss Cardenas fix what they can and even
refer back to the electrician they got
off in the first episode we always see
the Vigilante side of heroism and
Daredevil but what I like about this
series especially this episode is we
also see the street level non-powered
normal civilian heroism and Karen foggy
and Claire throughout the MCU we get a
ton of Sidekicks that do what they can
to support the hero whether it's
Spider-Man Doctor Strange or even Iron
Man but in the Netflix series the best
friends or partners are doing the best
that they can for the City without or
with very minimal direct help from that
Superhero Claire wants to help the city
so she became a Doctor Karen is trying
to take down her past employer through
Justice and foggy is learning to help
those in need no questions asked
something we sort of got from Cassie and
quantumania with her activism I just
like seeing these non-powered
individuals also Thrive as a reflection
to what we can do as people in our
normal society that's right like when
Superman became a farmer no so we're
back at the precinct with Christian
Blake the corrupt cop his phone rings
and immediately Daredevil is in action
flipping over the fence so quietly Blake
had no idea what happened then promptly
punched him in the face Blake pulls out
the gun just to have his forearm
immediately Twisted behind him and
shoved against the wall then we get the
good old Daredevil interrogation back
and forth Blake denies the truth about
the irrigation until Daredevil almost
breaks his arm when Daredevil accuses
Blake of killing the Russian in
interrogation for using fisk's name
Blake claps back at Daredevil saying so
what I heard you'd like to kill Russia
too you chopped off and it told his head
terrible pauses before going along with
the fake narrative smart move make him
scared he realizes he can get close to
the fist if people believe he killed
Anatoly plus everyone's afraid of a man
who can decapitate someone with a car
door so he asks where to find Vladimir
next unfortunately Blake doesn't know
and is telling the truth once Daredevil
hears his heartbeat immediately Blake
insults him and charitable knocks him
out kicking him directly in the face and
finds his ringing cell phone lying on
the ground who is this guy he's worse
than this back with Fisk and Vanessa
we're trying this date thing again a new
restaurant and a new dress for Vanessa I
love this one it's brown and in the last
episode she made a remark about
chocolate being her downfall and wanting
to step out of her comfort zone to which
Fisk agrees because she looks great in
chocolate colored dresses I'm obsessed
with this Fisk learned from the last
time and the entire restaurant is empty
so there should be no interruptions this
time this is when they discuss the
importance of honesty Vanessa makes it
clear a big part of this relationship
has to build on a foundation of trust
and spoilers no man has trust no man
ever will Vanessa do not trust men This
truly loves this woman though and begins
to open up started Easy by telling her
the wine they'd like tonight then this
quiet delicate scene is immediately
darkened when we see Vladimir's hand
bringing out a washcloth of blood into a
steel bucket and God could never have
prepared me to watch Vladimir clean the
blood off his decapitated brother's
chest I hated the same he's so gentle
and it's so sad he's lightly stroking
the blood away from his brother's
tattoos then Turk enters apologizing on
behalf of the Headless brother on the
table in front of them Turk tells
Vladimir an old friend from Rikers had a
black expensive SUV covered in blood and
brains delivered to his chop shop on the
edge of Hell's Kitchen said the man was
big white and bald Vladimir knows it
must be Wilson Fisk but Turk also
mentions they reference the man with the
black mask so now two Vladimir it sounds
like Wilson and Daredevil are working
together now he's probably noid Fisk has
been playing them and working against
them all along like this wanted a war is
about to begin with a 1 million hit on
his head foggy and Karen are fixing Miss
Cardenas sink now flushed with water
huzzah baby steps in excitement Miss
Cardenas Cooks some a meal she cooks at
the downstairs apartment where they have
power and it makes a homemade Guatemala
dish for Karen inside your foggy but
also because she's initiating a date
between the two so Karen and foggy are
basically having a little candlelit
dinner date hopefully in all this love
you didn't forget about Daredevil back
at his apartment Claire is going through
Blake's old ass Samsung phone and
unfortunately there's nothing on it the
phone is basically empty no contacts no
numbers no nothing it's a burner phone
one text came through from a blocked
number with a bunch of locations to
allegedly where the Russians are 47th
and 12th 48th 9th 42nd and 10th 44th and
11th and remember back to the first
episode where Nobu is going over the
blueprints to Hell's Kitchen we get a
glimpse to where the young boy the black
Sky would be held and you could see the
numbers on the phone or at least a block
away from the area of interest on nobu's
map so the Russians are perfectly placed
around the black sky and when the bombs
go off later it's no surprise no boost
Conquest is safe in the center Matt
realizes one of the locations is also
the truck or restaurant where they took
the boy in episode 2. Majid Deuces this
is where the Russians are and before he
leaves we have to talk about the two
side of the same coin that is Wilson
Fisk and Daredevil Vanessa had a
heart-to-heart with Fisk about honesty
and how important it is then we see
Daredevil and Claire arguing about
transparency and Assurance it's like the
lines are getting too foggy and clear
Claire's right Daredevil's becoming the
exact person he swore to fight he's no
longer protecting Hell's Kitchen he's
painting it red his morality is clouded
and judgment completely unclear once he
realizes how deep he's in it'll be too
late like it's already already starting
off he's going downhill back on Vanessa
and fist's date they have some more
small talk over wine she mentions dating
a prince with an ascot to which Kingpin
replies Ascot that's a bit much I can't
do his voice actually I naturally sound
like his voice right now Ascot that's a
bit much and the writers did this as a
shout out to kingpin's older depictions
with an ascot clearly it's a great time
until Vanessa mentioned sleeping with
someone in the past and Fisk is
completely uncomfortable at the idea but
he can close a man's neck and a door 22
times and that's nothing to Shadow over
so I guessed whatever cool he makes her
smile though when he says he wish he had
used that same line on her the first
time they met but she's glad that he
didn't then we begin the honest
conversation and this tells me Vanessa
about Wesley even referring to him as a
friend and you'd be so happy to hear
that it was so sweet and I was like you
call him tell him that he's a friend
then Vanessa asks what business he's in
to which he says rebuilding the city she
says that sounds like an artist and I
say gentrification yeah he rubs his
cufflinks and admits that they belong to
his father and he wears him every day to
remember him he tells where he passed
when he was a boy but you know how now
this is when Fisk notices Vanessa's
purse citing that there's a gun in it he
can tell from the weight distribution
she remarks it's a 22. it's just so
interesting because if you go back and
re-watch earlier there is a moment where
wasn't this totally clockster she walks
up and he could just tell from the
muscle tension in her arm that there is
a gun in that bag this man has studied
every inch of this woman and knows how
she carries herself when there is no
weight and when there is weight on it
creepy if you ask me her chest starts to
pick up in speed and you can't really
tell if it's out of irritation or fear
she knows who Fisk is and how he
perfectly dances around her questions to
which he replies his lasting goal is to
repair the city which is true in his
eyes no matter who he must kill to make
sure the city is cleaned up and with
full honesty Vanessa tells him that she
brought a gun because she knows this is
dangerous but wants a reason to stay and
you've got to love this woman I love her
so much it's a problem I mean look
Melania gets to have her fans too right
what this is Marvel Melania this is this
is and once you said that it makes
complete sense and I can't love her
anymore I take him back I take it
completely back he continues to tell her
he doesn't like the violence he must
commit he doesn't find the pleasure in
the cruelty but the city needs to die
before it can be repor and if that's not
setting up Daredevil porn again I don't
know what is they're calling the shots
none of this scares Vanessa not a single
bit so he gives Fisker gun and now he
must protect her by his side and cue the
fireworks it's about to happen it's
about to rumble in a minute back with
Vladimir Turk got the news where Fisk is
and he's on his way little does he know
Daredevil sits above them like a like a
Gargoyle on the roof eavesdropping on
their conversation every time we see him
perched on a roof I'm like is he a
pigeon back with foggy and Karen
flirting over dinner this candle at
dinner is actually very cute I'll give
them that it's very sweet then Karen
asks about Matt's love life to which
foggy says a lot of dumb stuff about
Matt knowing which woman to help because
they're hot which rightfully makes Karen
uneasy foggy doesn't know that weird
sexual attention they had in Matt's
apartment so Karen is learning about
Matt the wrong way then Karen asked if I
get to touch her face so she knows how
that Caesar and thank God we cut away
from this scene because I hate it next
there's a blind man walking in the alley
it's one of Madame gal's men the people
we saw working in the first episode
Daredevil pops out of nowhere and
Spartan kicks this goon in the back
against the brick wall they start
throwing punches and again it's dark so
Daredevil's winning this fight and
inside the warehouse men begin grabbing
guns and vladimirs putting on a
bulletproof vest it's the worst timing
Sergey sees the gal's Delivery Man and
asks are we waiting on a delivery from
GAO and Madame GAO has sent a suicide
bomber to blow up the Russian Warehouse
they know instantly and dive through the
open door to get away the explosion
blasts the steel door off its hinges
hitting Daredevil who perfectly holds
the man he's fighting and the way the
impact but it still knocks him out
unconscious on the ground back with this
awkward face touching another explosion
ruptures through Hell's Kitchen
shattering Miss Cardenas class from the
window it explodes cutting Miss
gardena's face and knocking fogging
Karen directly off their chairs clearly
the location sent to the cell phone are
the locations of the explosions but also
the Russian warehouses all the dates
tonight are ruined but Vanessa watches
the flames in golf the city and Fisk
uses the boy being kidnapped in the
earlier episodes as an excuse for the
explosions which could be true he's
ultimately doing this for a better
future in his own sadistic way in that
future may or may not include Vladimir
and his men thank God Daredevil Also
Rises From the Ashes Like a Phoenix and
here's Sergey asking for Vladimir and
he's back in Action a steel door that
doesn't stop him and Turk again not
surprisingly is on Fisk side sitting in
a car with Wesley telling him everything
he knew and it feels like we closed
every single episode with a reveal and
it's Wesley in a car trapping or talking
to someone using them or doing something
honestly Great Character to play you get
a lot of screen time Wesley admits it
takes time to keep Vladimir off bound
they had Turk tell him the man in Black
Mask was brought up in this conversation
there were always 10 steps ahead they
had this planned out from the jump back
with Sergey and Vladimir exactly what
Claire was afraid of begins to happen
Daredevils caught by the police beating
the crap out of Vladimir and this man's
already down there's no need to beat him
up anymore he is literally crawling the
anger is clearly coming over him and it
gets the best of him and this is how we
close the episode that's where we leave
it uh so thank you so much for watching
episode five of our road to Born Again
Daredevil re-watch series we will be
back to talk about episode 6 condemned
in the meantime subscribe to new
Rockstar subscribe to the Deep dive
Channel I'm doing a Guardians of the
Galaxy rewatch currently it's really fun
stuff and it gets aboard the scrolling
Network by grabbing something from our
merch store nerd riot.shop subscribe to
new rockstars on YouTube and all social
platforms follow Jessica at Lulu
underscore Clemons you can follow me at
eavos we'll see you next time bye
dude on this Sprite got me going crazy
[Music]